[Music]
this is star talk
i'm your host neil degrasse tyson you're
a personal astrophysicist and i got my
coho chuck nice checking baby hey what's
happening neil all right all right i bet
you don't know what we're gonna do today
no new thing we're doing today uh oh
this is gonna be a
stuff you thought you knew
like a second installment of that right
we did this once before and it really
caught on
and people wanted a little more of that
kind of action it's because people want
to know they want to know they want to
know more
more and more they want to know new
stuff plus if the old stuff they knew
was wrong they want to fix it
usually most of the time
so right off the top just so you know
i'm going to talk about the metric
system in the united states
then i'm going to talk about the
difference between speed and
acceleration
then i'm going to talk about heat
shields
of re-entering spacecraft
interesting okay that's a little it's an
odd sort of collection there but there's
you'll feel it i think as we move
through it all right
so let's let's start let's start right
out are you old enough to remember
when jimmy carter said we're going
metric
in the united this is the early 1970s do
you remember this i do not
there was a whole commission to
convert the united states to the metric
system
yes well
good to know that that worked out so
well
[Laughter]
as i drink from my 16-ounce glass
so good to know
so good to know um so
so i joke about this because back then
and today um drug dealers have always
been metric
right just think about that
they don't sell cocaine in pounds that's
in kilos that's right
so
that'll get you the same that that gets
you another measurement of time
one that einstein had hadn't explored
yet that's right
yes exactly
so i've heard people joke that if we had
put drug lords as head of the metric
commission in the united states we all
would have been metric within months
right
wait are you talk that afternoon
after that afternoon we'd have been 100
metric and and high
so what i want to try to communicate is
that we're not as bad as it may seem
we are much farther along
than
we even admit to ourselves
in this conversion i just want to sort
of put it out there
okay and i'm going to tell you why
because i don't want you to feel bad
about this now i is a scientist we're
metric from the beginning right that's
not even a thing engineers are a little
later in the in the in the listening but
scientists we speak internationally
we and that's the international
system that gets used okay right so in
fact it's called system international
the si system of units the meter the
kilogram
the second is in there but everybody
uses the second so
so you know the french came up with the
metric system did you know this no
wonder we don't use it
[Laughter]
when you get this editorial card
so it got implemented in 1789 and what
was happening then
in france
1789.
89. in part inspired by what happened in
the united states uh was that the best
deal storming and all that yeah
french revolution yeah right yeah so
part of that sort of overthrowing of all
previous order that was the occasion if
you're gonna do it that's a good time to
do it right in addition to the rolling
heads you throw in the metric system we
need everywhere to figure out how these
heads roll faster
how is it that we get to head to rava
we're gonna put the basket down let it
roll and we shall measure it in no way
i seize your hair go from the guillotine
as it went
down
as i smoke a cigarette and watch
[Laughter]
that's exactly how it happened
all right
so
they
uh
so do you know the original definition
of a meter
no okay so somebody had to come up with
that right right i mean it's pretty
obvious a foot is somebody's foot right
in the met in the in the imperial units
but a meter
was
1 10 millionth
the distance
from the north pole
to the equator
on a path that went through the paris
observatory so that's that's how it
began and
that they became standardized then they
created an artifact
out of platinum and iridium an alloy of
those two and that there was an etch
mark on one end and on the other and
that was the length of the meter that
you can go and reference it uh in france
uh so that you can then take a meter
home with you that was the correct line
so that's an example and they had an
object called the kilogram and it's in
at vault
and there it is 1 kg all right but point
is it had a beginning and all this
metric beginning was in 1789 i'm just
saying okay
okay so
uh so here we are in the united states
and we we kind of have metric envy a
combination of metric envy and
and imperial pride
all right we're using fahrenheit and
inches and meters and cups and
tablespoons and we're damn proud of it
but at the end of the day i think it's
like
yeah maybe we kind of want a little bit
of metric in our lives so i just want to
impress upon you
we already do are you ready
i am ready and and by the way i'm saying
we've been inching
towards the metric system for decades i
see what you did there
okay so first of all
we had metric money
from the start
okay this sounds like bitcoin i'm not
sure if i'm in
how many pennies in a dime how many
dimes in a dollar yeah all right base 10
yeah it's it's base 10 all the way at
the time england was using pounds and
shillings and pence and that and i said
i still don't know how that system
worked to this day and i'm a full-grown
adult who've thought about it okay so
so first we had metric money
put that in the bank okay all right what
else do we have oh
our photography
has largely been metric
from the beginning
all right there's 35 millimeter film
right you didn't measure that in inches
right you had a 50 millimeter lens all
lenses are measured all lenses are
measured in
now there was some film formats there
were inches there was four by five right
and eight by ten those are the larger
formats but most of all the others was
metric
and the lenses were metric you go to the
movie 70 millimeter wide you know
2001 a space odyssey 1968 in 70
millimeters no one was freaking out that
you saw mm next to the 70. right okay
okay so
photography was in all right what else
was in oh our medicine has been metric
like
practically forever
all right so you have you know it's one
cc of some drug or one it's what is a cc
it's a cubic centimeter that's what a cc
is no doctor gives you a shot of an
ounce
penicillin
[Laughter]
i need an ounce of penicillin stat
doctor you're gonna kill him he's dead
jim he's already dead he's already dead
so
so medical dosing has been metric like
forever okay uh add to that
our nutrition labels
were metric from the beginning
how many grams of fat oh that's how many
milligrams
okay
just look on any nutritional label it's
all metric and it's been that way and no
one is freaking out by looking at this
okay
how many grams this how many grams that
so
what do we have in the banknote we got
we got metric money metric medicine
metric photography metric um nutrition
labels what else
oh
we've got
metric
bottles of soft drink
you've never in your life purchased a
quart of pepsi
i have a leader no you haven't it's a
liter
okay
a liter slightly more than a quart but
close enough you know for most purposes
but so one liter two liter three liter
bottles of pepsi that's right okay
so
uh our larger volumes non-dairy
larger bottles have been metric for a
long time
okay for decades it's funny because
everything you're mentioning right now
are all global commodities
yes soda is global photography is global
good point we're not shipping milk
that's correct right yeah uh
pharmaceuticals are global
it's all global stuff that you're
talking okay well well let me keep going
all right okay i'm not i'm not done yet
one of the last things i thought would
have changed okay
was
the volume displacement of
the pistons in an engine
okay
i drove a car
that was a 400 cubic inch v8 engine
that's right nobody measures it in cubic
inches anymore not anymore it's in
liters that's how you one liter two lead
and that leader if you ever wondered is
not the volume of any liquid in it is
the volume of the cylinders
in the
in the engine block itself 4.0 liter
yeah that's right it's a measure of how
much sort of
uh movement and power you're getting out
of the engine it's one of several
measures you can invoke so that's metric
okay okay and uh
shall i keep going about it those are
important things i think
okay now we still have fahrenheit yes
and we still have
sort of miles and
and our cooking
is not really metric so it's like three
holdouts cooking
distance
cooking measurements distance
temperature and baking
okay right so when people say america
you got to join us with the rest of the
world with the metric system we kind of
already have a b
i don't i'm i don't feel even as a
scientist speaking i don't feel some
great urge to give up fahrenheit and
feet in inches i'll tell you why
when you visit another country
um
part of what it is to sort of
blend in and to fit in and to learn is
to learn what their customs are
in america jack we use fahrenheit and
just deal with it okay
i mean you know i'm not going over to my
neighbors and trying to borrow 236
milliliters of sugar
i'm new to the neighborhood do you have
236 milliliters of sugar
so anyway i think we come a long way so
we're inching and maybe dairy comes next
i don't know
um i kind of like the fact that you know
eggs come in a dozen a dozen is a nice
historical baker's quantity i like that
and so i'm i'm cool with that let me
remind you
that we had a mission to mars where the
engineers were using the imperial system
and the scientists were using the metric
system and there's a point where two
calculations had to come together and
their their units were not converted to
match
and so the propulsion that was put into
play to go into orbit around mars was
the wrong thrust and it basically
overshot mars completely and so we lost
you know 100 million dollar spacecraft
because of not because two systems
didn't match it's not because we weren't
on metric
it's that
because the system was not turned into a
common um a common set of measures that
that's why had that been done we
wouldn't have had the problem even if
the engineers continued to use
a feet and then inches
wow
that
that right well
okay that was egg on our face that was
that looked bad especially for nasa
without a doubt yeah what do you mean
yeah it's like missed it by that much
almost it doesn't count yeah if you're
trying to reach a planet no it doesn't
count damn
oh yeah that's awful yeah all right so i
just wanted to say we're inching towards
the metric system and we're there in
ways you probably hadn't thought about
and so that's my little bit of that
yes and we're going to take a break and
when we come back i'm going to talk
about the difference between speed and
acceleration
right on when star talk returns
we're back star talk
this is a stuff you thought you knew
edition i think it's our second
installment chuck we did this once
before yes
and
i i it's
i i think you like it i do it's now
called stuff i still don't
i know don't know this stuff
all right so for this middle segment
i want to talk about the difference
between speed and acceleration okay okay
all right so there there's a nice scene
nice there's a
rememberable
scene in the movie top gun
where they just came out of there out of
their planes and they're holding their
helmet and what what does one of them
say to the other as they high-five each
other i've got the need
for speed
okay
i thought it was great
i feel i feel the need for speed and i
want to
push back on that if i may
okay you want to push back on the need
for speed yes i am oh no
because i claim that
their speed is
almost irrelevant
to what it is their ex their it's
triggering their emotions
really yeah yeah
because for example
right now
uh at our latitude on earth the rotation
of earth is carrying us
due east at 800 miles an hour
are you saying i feel the need for speed
and this is great no you
may explain why i keep throwing up every
time
every time i stand up it could be a
reason why
i vomit
so no but say see i'm about to say
that what we think of as motion sickness
is not motion sickness it's acceleration
sickness
okay okay so earth is in orbit around
the sun 18 miles per second
that all of these speeds are way faster
than anything they're doing in their
airplane this is true so if they're not
really after speed wow 18 miles in a
second in a second one second from my
house i would overshoot the bronx i mean
you know i would overshoot brooklyn yeah
where i am right now you'd end up in the
long island sound right
in one second okay
so you you live in jersey
you cross the hudson river the width of
manhattan all over brooklyn and then you
come out
water oh my god that's amazing so here's
the thing
when you are moving at constant speed
your body has no idea
you're moving at any speed at all
okay it's only when your speed changes
that you get some sense of motion
and by definition
when your speed changes it's an
acceleration now in physics an
acceleration can be positive or negative
in in the english language we have
another word for when it's negative
acceleration and it's just called what
deceleration deceleration okay so so i
might say acceleration in this in my
next few minutes i mean increasing
or decreasing it doesn't matter either
positive or negative excel accelerate
okay
when that happens
you feel it
and that's what you're reacting to
all right by the way think of velocity
okay so velocity a change in velocity is
an acceleration
but sup and a velocity has a direction
right but suppose you're banking a turn
your direction is constantly changing
well if velocity has to have one
direction now i'm changing the direction
that's also an acceleration
so here's my point
when you're in a moving object no matter
its speed
if the direction
or the speed changes you are
accelerating and when you feel an
acceleration
your body is going to respond
if you accelerate forward your body will
be thrown backwards if you s if you
decelerate quickly your
body goes forwards if you bank a turn
you lean
against the door or breaks the person
next to you in the front seat
so that's how you know you're
accelerating because your body is
responsible responding in this way
so these folks said i feel the need for
speed it's because they're doing barrel
rolls in their plane and upside down
and all the stuff they're doing that's
what they're feeling
but if they were going perfectly at mach
1 2 3 4 or 30
they wouldn't be saying i feel the need
for speed
because that's not anything they would
notice this was been the complaint about
the lexus car when it first came out the
lexus was a you know a luxury car and
that ride was smooth
i read one commentary and it said it's
like
sitting on your living room couch while
you're driving your car that sounds
lovely okay
so nobody who feels the need for speed
is buying a lexus
they want a car that can bank turns and
and go from zero to 60 in whatever how
many seconds you're talking about that's
an acceleration
yeah but it doesn't sound good to say i
feel the need for acceleration
[Laughter]
it's a celebration of acceleration now i
just sound like jesse jackson
you know
that's what i'm saying it's because my
man rhymes anything it comes out of his
mouth celebration of acceleration
keep alive
okay
so
so that's all i'm trying to tell you so
that's why
they'll they will give top speed when
you're buying a car they will give a top
speed um
but they will also give 0 to 60 or 0 to
50 in a certain amount of time so that
is the change in velocity
over a certain amount of time and so
if you change velocity in less and less
amount of time your acceleration is
higher and higher and higher that's why
they keep trying to drop the
acceleration time
then it's more ahead it's more head
snapping now right yeah
now
actually let's take a look at tesla
oh because it was high right but it'd be
true for
any well-made electric car will have
very high acceleration yeah even at low
speeds right
teslas can accelerate 0-60 in three four
seconds yeah that's good yeah and i've
been in it and you can feel it it's like
yeah okay okay so now watch
let's kick it up a notch you ready i
don't think you're ready are you seated
okay all right i'm sorry okay
there it is hold on
i don't want to accelerate too fast
i better strap
it okay so if acceleration
is the rate of change of your velocity
okay so if that if you rate changes
quickly you have high acceleration you
will feel this response all the more
okay all right
if acceleration is the rate and change
in your velocity
what happens when you have a rate of
change of your acceleration
oh my goodness let me guess
your head explodes yes well
okay so if you have a rate of change of
acceleration that has a term in physics
it's called the jerk
okay
all right so
so watch this
oh man that's great okay so watch what
happens you ready go ahead um so i'm
headed towards a brick wall
i'm trying to come up with these
examples on the spot heading towards a
brick wall and so i should put on my
brakes so you put on your brakes
okay
and while you put on your brakes you
feel yourself you're leaning into the
the shoulder strap okay
when you hit the wall
your body jerks forward
because you had a steady
slowing down of your speed
until your speed went to zero
instantly
so that is a rate of change of your
acceleration and then you feel a jerk
okay
but what
why don't we run into a wall
okay so the jerk is what actually does
sort of musculoskeletal damage in an
accident
okay okay because we can sustain an
acceleration when they say i have one g
two g those are pure constant
accelerations but if you go from one g
to six g's in an instant your whole body
snaps
right that's this and so the jerk is one
reverse and the same thing reversed
correct
so what you're basically saying is
jumping out of a 20-story window doesn't
kill you
that's correct
if there were no ground right he's
alright
oh man
so so that's uh velocity
uh acceleration
and jerk so almost every and there's
some cars they say in this car you can
feel the road if you ever test drive
like a sports car they tell you that
right well what does it mean to feel the
road
well if the if the road were perfectly
smooth you wouldn't feel anything so the
fact that the road has certain bumps
the lexus wouldn't feel those bumps
because the tires are adjusting to it
but your sports car which has quote
rigid suspension it is rigid enough so
that you're feeling that all right so
you and the road and the bumps and
wiggles and the turns and twists on the
road you're feeling it all
nice you feeling it and so you get so
this is what you like this is what you
seek
this is what the sports enthusiast is
actually after even if they're not
self-conscious of it
because if they only want at high speeds
you can just get on a you know get on a
high-speed train
and then you don't feel it because
they're smooth no you want to you want
to bank the turns and feel it that
reminds me of a guy on the i was on the
turnpike and a guy comes by on a
motorcycle and he's already i'm doing 80
so he had to be doing a little faster
than 80 because he came by me
and then he pulls back on the throttle
and pops a wheelie
at 80 miles an hour
and pulls off okay
so
and and i and i'm pretty sure he was
like i feel the need for acceleration
and with the high accelerating cars of
course a constant acceleration is a is a
one-time thing by the way
you either press yourself back or
forward or lean
one way or another and any abrupt change
in that
creates this this jolt but even if you
if you're if you're going at zero and
then you floor it
there is the initial head snap
okay
that's a very high moment of
acceleration but then you stays that way
until you like hit the brick wall and
then you're snapping another way so
anyhow i just put i'm just putting all
this out there
in case you didn't know
so uh all i can say is please take
neil's word for everything he just said
let's not try the brick wall experiment
for ourselves
okay
we're not responsible for anybody
who crashes the car into a wall all
right just take his word for it chuck
one last thing okay all right so if
you're in an airplane
and the airplane wants to just go left
let's say right in the air
put the roll down the
hand on the window put his hand pilot
puts his hand out
all right so
so in the old days the plane would turn
and you would feel yourself lean
one direction or another
depending on which direction it was
turning and if you had sort of a drink
in your glass you would see the level of
the liquid
tip inside the glass right that doesn't
happen anymore
why
yep it doesn't happen anymore
the pilot's there just for show all
right computers fly airplanes and here's
what it does
when you're just sitting there doing
nothing on an airplane going nowhere
gravity points straight down into your
chair you have a glass of water gravity
points vertically down so the water
level is horizontal okay
now the plane takes off while it's
gaining speed you press back you'll see
the liquid you're not being served
liquid at this point but it would
actually change what it thinks is
horizontal
while you're accelerating all right so
now you get up to
you know 30 000 feet you're going 500
miles an hour that's speed way faster
than any car anybody's driving today so
so there it is and everything is level
and horizontal once again so now watch
what happens
if while the plane
makes a left turn
depending on its speed it can angle the
fuselage
so that you're urged to lean to the s to
the right in that case is compensated by
the banking of the plane itself
and so
but then it and the computer does it
perfectly
so
if you have a drink and you're sitting
there the plane can make a complete
circle
and you will never notice it because the
combination of all the vectors
line up
in that computed trajectory of the plane
so that everything goes straight into
the bottom of the plane and into the
chair
even though everybody's actually tipped
to the side the fact that it's on a
banked turn
compensates for that and so your drink
is always horizontal that's why no one
even if you if your blinds are closed
you'll never even know you're returning
next time you come into the airport do
this experiment get your drink put it
there notice it's level open the shade
look out the window and watch the plane
turn
to come in for a landing and as it does
it the water level is completely
horizontal in your glass
that's cool the only problem though is
the computer can't talk to you and that
disaffected i'm bored out of my mind
comforting pilot voice
ladies and gentlemen we're on our final
descent to jfk just want to let you know
that we know you have other choices to
fly and we thank you for flying with us
if you look out the left side of your
plane uh don't do that you should look
at the water in your glass right now
exactly do some science while you do it
all right so when we come back
i've got another segment here of stuff
you thought you knew so chuck you you
want another one of these i want another
one any hints on what it might be oh
yeah it's just on on heat shields
oh sweet
let's do it right okay all right when
star talk returns
we're back star talk chuck nice tweeting
a chuck nice comic dude thank you sir
yes we have some good stuff lately keep
it going thank you all right all right
so i want to talk about heat shields on
aircraft okay
so we all know that they exist
and you know why they exist to stop
phasers from penetrating the ship's hull
i didn't say
i
that's a different kind of shield oh my
heat shield damn not phaser shields oh
man
damn oh you don't want to hang around
anymore okay
ordinary heat shields okay you've always
seen you've heard about it you've read
about it and you know what they're for
um i would guess because it gets hot
so they're going to shield you from the
heat
okay that's not their purpose
what
yeah that's not that's not why they
exist well that's a very deceptive name
i thought about that that's right yeah
that's an
extremely deceptive name
it implies that you're gonna get hot and
burn up so you have to protect yourself
from it until you put in these shields
so that you don't die
so why is nasa toying with my emotions
like this this cause now you care
because the astronauts is living fleshy
things inside the capsule right okay so
if it's not to stop me from burning up
and dying
what's it for okay so here it is ready
you need heat shields because
any object in orbit
is going in
especially low earth orbit it's going 18
000 miles an hour
right okay that's right that's fast so
if you do the math that's like five
miles per second second eight kilometers
a second all right so
that's fast well if you're going that
fast in any other situation you'd put on
the brakes
right you would find some way to slow
down
well spacecraft
don't also carry fuel
to slow down with
no retro rockets no retroright
now they do
well no not really no well well it
depends wait hold on when they're coming
back to earth no retro rockets okay
still no retro rocks still not retro
rockets so but you're right it would be
called retro rockets so whatever here
i'm going so fast let me flip the engine
the other way or point the nozzle and
blow exhaust opposite the direction i'm
going that will slow me down
okay if we had that
that's all you'd have to do to come out
of orbit is blow exhaust out the other
direction until you have zero velocity
pop a parachute and then glide down to
earth yeah uh like like in a ship like a
uh all engines reverse you know and you
see the propeller stop and goes opposite
directions
correct correct okay that's all you'd
have to do but
to carry the fuel that you're not going
to use until you want to come out of
orbit you that takes fuel to put the
fuel that you're not burning and so we
said we're not going to do this
because we don't have to
let's take all of this kinetic energy
this energy of motion
and let the atmosphere burn it off
let the atmosphere sweep it away
so we they're called heat shields but
you know what they are they're
aerobraking
it's an aerobraking system
uh-huh you want this
because you intentionally didn't bring
fuel or breaks to slow you down so you
use air to do it
so what do they do here's the capsule in
orbit moving real fast okay
and it's set up in such a way that the
bottom section
uh it'll always sort of dangle with that
coming first
and it's it's this big blunt thing that
plows into the atmosphere the atmosphere
is i'm not going to want to let you do
that but i'm coming through anyway
there's not aerodynamic at all it's it's
totally not well it's it's air having
that it's not going to be turbulent um
it'll stability come through
but
right you are you want to maximize this
resistance and in so doing you heat up
the bottom side of the craft
where does the energy come from that's
heating the bottom of the craft
the are friction i know but
okay what was the original source of
that energy
what do you mean uh it was your speed of
the crash oh that's right the craft
itself flying in at 18 000
thank you thank you we gotta get rid of
that energy somehow so
here it comes all right let us come down
and work our way into the atmosphere and
in the upper layers there's not as much
air molecules but there it is and you
get sort of shock waves and friction and
all manner of other sort of
communicating molecules all right and
that speed
becomes heat
energy the kinetic energy becomes heat
energy now if it only becomes heat
energy that's not good enough because
then you'll still burn up
you've got to whisk away that heat
energy so
right okay
send it somewhere else get it out of
here so in the old days and even in many
modern capsules
the quote heat shields are onion layers
of burnable substance
oh so
they are heating up and then they're
peeling away they're peeling away so the
so all the heat
is
actually like wicking like moisture
like that i'd like that analogy you're
wicking away the heat and every time you
do this the thing is slowing down and
continues to slow down and depending on
how much kinetic energy you have add on
a few more layers
okay when they came back from the moon
they re-entered the atmosphere at a
higher speed than just coming out of low
earth orbit so the the moon crafts
coming back had more heat shield layers
than the other spacecraft
wow
that's by the way it's aerobraking
that's what it is ingenious it is and
it's blunt and it's low-tech and it
worked every time i don't know who
thought of that but that guy should have
got a doughnut
i'm telling you
that's the part of your reward
he should have got a parking space
because that is says the new yorker
where parker is highly valuable somebody
somebody was really thinking i mean yeah
yeah and it works and it and it works
every time so so it's so it's i think
the correct word is it ablates
ablate so you're saying whisking it
ablates and so and it goes away and when
you're done and you have low enough
speed then you deploy your parachute and
you just dip
dip in
that is genius there is a sci-fi movie
where they are in orbit around some
planet i think it might be mars but it's
some planet i don't remember which
and they're on some stable orbiting
platform but there's one of these
platforms that sort of rotates with
the rotating planet
okay and a guy falls off the platform
towards the planet
and that's bad and you see and then he
goes down and then you see him disappear
in a puff of smoke
no
just because you're entering an
atmosphere doesn't mean you're gonna
burn up right the burning up is not an
inherent feature of passing through an
atmosphere the burning up comes from
getting rid of the speed you had to
maintain 18 000 miles an hour when we
landed on the moon moon's got no
atmosphere right how do you get a soft
landing there can't use a parachute
can't use aerobraking
they needed retro rockets got to have
retro rockets yeah yep
there it is mars has a thin atmosphere
so that one had parachute big parachute
plus retro rockets plus aerobraking all
three to get the rovers on mars
oh you drop a trampoline
thank you well i'll bring that up at the
next nasa meeting okay
chuck knight says trampoline
why did it take us five days to land on
the moon
[Laughter]
yeah if it's a perfect trampoline it
will never stop it'll never dissipate
the energy it'll just keep bouncing
right you want it to the energy has to
dissipate somehow it'd heat up the
springs the energy can't just disappear
it has to
transmute into some other form and then
get whisked away as you said so you
should i think you should always think
of heat shields as
aerobraking systems rather than oh you
need this otherwise you'll burn up no
you need it otherwise you'll crash
that's so cool and that's
really cool oh and uh in the movie 2010
ostensibly the sequel to 2001 they came
to jupiter and they aerobraked around
jupiter they had some really good uh
visual effects for the day
and to sh and they're inside the craft
they're saying oh wow this is uh i wish
i could see this from the outside this
aerobraking basically any spacecraft
with heat shields coming through an
atmosphere is error-breaking
any time so that was not some new thing
it was portrayed as some new innovative
concept but of course we do that all the
time in fact
their spacecraft they come into mars
and their orbit is highly elongated
that's a hot uh that's a higher energy
orbit and they want to sort of
circularize it so when it dips down
closer to the atmosphere it makes sure
that the atmosphere slows it down a
little bit that eats some of the energy
and you can circularize an orbit on
purpose that way
so they just kind of like skipping rocks
skipping rocks i like that
i like that that's cool
so there you go chuck uh think of it as
um error breaking not heat shields for
the future very nice do not try this on
earth that's all i can say
please don't try this on earth but that
is a really cool concept and if you fall
out of your spaceship and and fall
towards a planet uh if you die it won't
have to be because you burned up
right it'd just be because you hit the
planet
way that dude was going to die
[Laughter]
this was yet another episode of stuff we
thought you should know whether or not
you did
[Laughter]
all right chuck chuck
co-host always a pleasure all right neil
degrasse tyson as always keep looking up
[Music]
you